oh  [Applause]  [Music]  will the next victim please enter the  arena at this time if he will stand just  three minutes in the cage with old  what's your name kid the human spider  a human spider that's it that's the best  you got yeah oh that sucks the sum of  three thousand dollars will be paid to  the terrified  the deadly  the  amazing spiderman  my name's the human spider i don't care  good afternoon no he got my name wrong  yeah  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  oh my god  oh my legs oh god i can't feel my legs  [Applause]  hello guys  please lock the cage doors at this time  hey listen  some kind of mistake i didn't sign up  for cage match  hey  unlock the thing take the chain off hey  freak joe  you're going nowhere  i got you for three minutes  three minutes of plea time  [Applause]  what are you doing up there staying away  from you  that's a cute outfit did your husband  give it to you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  okay  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you